[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 actualités et des
deux sorties pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 27 mai
c'est la principale préoccupation de la
campagne des élections législatives le
pouvoir d'achat l'inflation atteint 4,5
pour cent en mars dernier face à
l'augmentation du coût de la vie les
yvelinois tentent de s'organiser exemple
au marché de fontenay-le-fleury le 75e
festival de cannes se referme samedi
l'île de france a financé cette année 21
films sélectionnés et dont quatre en
compétition officielle focus également
sur la francilienne à lyss be no cours
qui présentait son dernier long métrage
à la quinzaine des réalisateurs revoir
paris et puis comme tous les vendredis
nos idées de sorties pour samedi et
dimanche dans les yvelines ce sera dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission est
pas de pont de l'ascension pour lui qui
est avec moi en plateau c'est bien sûr
bixente meilleure sortie steban bonjour
bixente jean grégory comme chaque
vendredi vous allez nous livrer votre
sélection des idées de sorties à faire
ce week-end dans les yvelines pour les
yvelinois justement qui sont restés dans
leur département quels sont les
suggestions aujourd'hui ça aujourd'hui
grégory et comme souvent de la musique
mais aussi des ballades alors sur la
scène ou en tracteur et puis en fin
d'émission retour sur la saison des
vide-greniers qui ouvre en jouant
souvent c'est la période on attend d'en
parler ce sera bien sûr tout à l'heure
dans le 7-8 week-end
l'actualité avec ce sujet du moment la
hausse des prix en mars dernier
l'inflation atteignait 85% des impacts
notamment sur le coût de l'énergie et de
l'alimentation alors comment s'en
sortent les événements et les petits
commerçants nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre au marché de
fontenay-le-fleury le reportage de
mathilde franck
au marché de fontenay-le-fleury on
trouve des fleurs de la viande des
fruits des légumes mais tous les
habitants font le même constat les prix
ont augmenté on commença à moins bon h
et déjà ces lettres c'est trop cher
regarder les prix aujourd'hui se nourrir
ça revient très cher quand on n'a pas le
temps de faire soi même la cuisine ou de
cuisiner ce que j'ai fait pendant des
années
et aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
alors pour éviter de perdre des clients
certains producteurs ont choisi de faire
des promotions en fonction de leur
récolte bat on sent que les gens ont
moins d'argent qui commence dès fois ils
vont acheter vraiment juste ce qu'il
faut ils vont pas en acheter plus oui
vont faire les promos comme la les
pommes de terre sont sont moins chères à
2 kilo les pommes donc ils vont prendre
des deux kido comme sa sauvegarde mais
pour d'autres c'est plus compliqué la
demande avait fait un petit papier
explicatifs pour nos clients justement
pour expliquer qu'avec même
l'augmentation
d'électricité du gaz et de la
la tonne de blé donc elle est passée à
la cadre hulk et je crois depuis le
temps oui ce sera à peu qu'on va doubler
surtout doublé depuis temps et du coup
bas comme nounou poule et
l'élevage de manière générale et nourris
avec des serial avec du maïs avec tout
ça pas forcément les bâtiments sont
chauffés au gaz à l'électricité non peut
pas répercuter tout ça enfin on est
obligé d'augmenter nos prix en france le
prix de l'électricité a été limitée à 4%
en février grâce au bouclier mis en
place par le gouvernement
une remise de 18 centimes sur les
carburants a aussi été instauré cette
mesure est d'ailleurs prolongé pour
quatre mois supplémentaires concernant
l'alimentation c'est environ une hausse
des prix de 14 % depuis janvier cela
concerne surtout les huiles la farine et
les pâtes le nouveau gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron devrait annoncer un
premier projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat en juin après les législatives
mais pouvoir d'achat qui est aussi un
sujet récurrent dans le programme des
candidats aux élections législatives
premier tour le 12 juin un deuxième tour
est fixé au 19 juin tv 78 vous aide à y
voir plus clair sur ce scrutin et ses
enjeux dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines aujourd'hui
nous nous intéressons à la 8e
circonscription est avec mathilde franco
bonjour mathilde de la rédaction de tv
78 déjà où se situe ce territoire et et
quelles communes composent cette
huitième circonscription alors grégory
cette huitième circonscription elle est
située au nord du département en vallée
de seine centré autour de la ville de
mantes la jolie elle regroupe 22
communes et représente 116000 yvelinois
environ avec des grandes villes comme
l'hymne et magnanville ou encore mantes
la ville et des petits villages comme
drocourt follainville dennemont ou
mental et le bois d'ailleurs en fonction
des zones géographiques on ne vote pas
de la même manière si à la
présidentielle les villes ont largement
donné leurs voix au candidat de la
france insoumise jean luc mélenchon les
villages ont préféré miser sur le
rassemblement national avec marine le
pen il ya donc une véritable fracture
une incompréhension entre villes et
campagnes dans la 8e circonscription et
qui est aujourd'hui le député à la tête
de cette circonscription qui est député
sortant alors c'est michelle wie les via
les pardons l'ancien maire de mantes la
jolie entre 2005 et 2010 cette qui
dirige cette huitième circonscription
lorsqu'il se présente il est devancé par
la candidate de la république en marche
khadija mounim au premier tour mais il
créé la surprise au second tour et
devient finalement députés c'est alors
le seul membre des républicains sur tout
le département a accédé à l'assemblée
nationale toutes les autres
circonscriptions ont été gagnées par la
majorité présidentielle
lrm modem ce renversement de tendance
est due en partie à la mobilisation de
pierre bédier le président du
département pour sa candidature alors
est-ce que le soutien de pierre bédier
va encore lui servir dans quelques
semaines ce n'est pas si sûr et là
quelques jours lors de la municipale
partielle de mantes la jolie le candidat
investi par le président du département
a largement perdu face à raphaël cogné
le maire l'ancien maire démissionnaire
poussé vers la sortie d'ailleurs
mathilde dans les candidats présents
face à michel vialay y aura notamment un
soutien de raphaël connu effectivement
grégory il s'agit des devises hervieu
ancienne adjointe chargée de la
transition écologique à la mairie de
mantes la jolie elle a toujours soutenu
raphaël cogner c'est d'ailleurs elle qui
l'a poussé à se représenter aujourd'hui
elle et sa première adjointe aux
affaires générales elle a donc été
investi par la majorité présidentielle
pour les législatives et sa candidature
ne fait pas l'unanimité déjà dans le
camp de pierre bédier on voit sa
nomination comme une déclaration de
guerre puis son investiture n'est pas
très bien vu non plus par certains
militants 40 et 1017 edwige hervieux
avait décidé de faire campagne pour
michel vialay et en 2020 la candidate a
pris sa carte chez les républicains mais
dans cette bataille des législatives
celui qui pourrait faire sa place et le
candidat du rassemblement national et
oui l'ancien maire de mantes la ville
cyril note pourrait tirer son épingle du
jeu professeur d'histoire géographie il
adhère au front national en 2010 il peut
compter sur les voix des habitants des
petits villages comme à follainville et
guîtres en cours ou marine le pen est
arrivé en tête au second tour de la
présidentielle
cependant les voies pour l'extrême
droite pourraient se partager avec la
candidature reconquête annecy car ceux
qui sont les autres candidats pour la
gauche il s'agit de benjamin
lucas il représentera la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et solidaire alias
la nuque coordinateur du mouvement
générations point s il est également
conseiller régional des eaux et des eaux
de france par d'où il fait partie des
candidats parachutés pour être dans les
yvelines et ce dernier croit à la
victoire de la gauche aux législatives
et souhaite que jean luc mélenchon ne
devienne premier ministre enfin parmi
les autres candidats bernard kossoko
sans étiquette politique
thierry gonot pour lutte ouvrière
jacques lefebvre pour le parti ouvrier
indépendant démocratique
françois blaise pour le parti
animalistes jean préau pour l'union des
démocrates musulmans et mélanie bekono
pour les patriotes on rappelle les dates
un les 12 et 19 joueurs pour ces
élections législatives merci matile pour
ce pan sur la 8e circonscription des
yvelines votre rubrique légal checking
du jour s'intéresse justement à ce
scrutin des législatives chaque vendredi
le collectif des surligneurs décryptent
pour vous l'actualité en ces temps de
campagne l'affichage électoral sauvage
pullulent mais que dit la loi éléments
de réponse avec raphaël mata duvignau
al'approche des élections législatives
nous assistons à la prolifération les
affiches électorales à poser de manière
sauvage les militants voir les candidats
n'hésitent pas à méconnaître la
réglementation en apposant des messages
à finalité électorale en dehors des
emplacements autorisés pourtant
plusieurs textes permettent d'intervenir
et à sanctions pénales sont également
prévues pour lutter contre ce fléau
d'abord l'article l 51 du code électoral
limite l'affichage au sol panneaux
officiels destinés à cet effet et ce
pendant les six mois précédant le
premier tour du jour du scrutin les
sanctions pénales sont également prévues
pouvant dans les cas extrêmes aller
jusqu'à une amende de 15000 euros et un
an d'emprisonnement
ensuite le code de l'environnement
fourni au maire si la ville adopté un
règlement local de publicité ou à défaut
le préfet des pouvoirs de sanction
illustratif en effet il leur est
possible de faire procéder au retrait
d'office d'un affichage et régulier
faute pour le contrevenant après mise en
demeure d'avoir régularisé la situation
il leur est également possible de faire
interdire toute publicité sur des
immeubles présentant un caractère
esthétique historique ou pittoresque le
camp nou ce retrait sera leur refacturer
à la personne fautive
précisons également que le procureur de
la république et les associations agrées
de protection de l'environnement
l'initiative de l'action judiciaire dans
ses hypothèses est que le code de ligne
de l'environnement prévoit une amende de
7500 euros pour les contrevenants
enfin le code de procédure civile permet
à toute personne qui apporte la preuve
d'un préjudice personnel et d'un trouble
manifestement illicite de saisir en
référé le président du tribunal
judiciaire pour deux nets sous astreinte
l'enlèvement les affiches illégales ce
sera vraisemblablement
l'initiative de candidats qui s'estiment
lésés et donc ici la ville ne pourra pas
agir de sa propre initiative au nom de
la protection de l'ordre public et du
cadre de vie des habitants et donc on le
constate face à ce fléau les outils
existent et les procédures sont
diversifiées voir complémentaires encore
faut-il avoir le courage de livrer
bataille contre ce qui semble être une
formidable et redoutable hydre de lerne
le 75e festival de cannes s'apprête à
baisser les rideaux la grande fête du
cinéma se clôture ce samedi 28 mai après
quasiment deux semaines de projection
sur la croisette chaque année la région
ile de france est présente à l'événement
21 films dont quatre en sélection
officielle ont été financés en 2022 par
la collectivité le conseil régional des
bourses 25 millions d'euros par an dans
le cinéma l'une de ses ambitions
notamment c'est d'aider au développement
des studios de tournage avec
l'embouteillage des productions
actuellement sur le territoire les
propos recueillis par nos confrères de
radio sensations la région à veut
soutenir les projets de développement de
studio existants ou de création de
studio là on a rencontré les
professionnels qui travaillent sur le
projet de coulommiers donc en seine et
marne on est également derrière le
projet de bry sur marne qui est un
projet conçu tout et qui est en train de
se décanter petit à petit on est aussi
en train d'essayer d'aider
sur le maintien d'une activité
cinématographique à saint-ouen c'est
compliqué parce que dans tous ces cas là
les deux derniers cas dont je parlais
c'est des contraintes extérieures qui
sont indépendantes de la région nantes
et il faut faire de la médiation
culturelle il faut être en
accompagnement et puis il ya aussi deux
nos projets des studios à brétigny donc
la région est vraiment à fond là-dedans
on veut que les studios se développe on
veut pouvoir faire de l'île de france la
première terre en matière d'accueil de
tournages des films des séries et des
créations fictives envoya nous allons
être en appui en soutien et puis
peut-être aussi en facilitateur et
accélérateur et dans un contexte de
recul de la fréquentation des salles
l'île de france souhaite également
développer l'éducation à l'image en
incitant les jeunes à aller au cinéma on
écoute à nouveau florence portelli
aujourd'hui on a une vraie difficulté à
remplir les salles alors s'élancer pas
que dans le cinéma il ya une
désaffection des publics à faire des
salles de spectacle mais celle de cinéma
aussi suite au cog hill et donc il ya
une réflexion drame en profonde à avoir
sur comment sensibiliser pour trouver
normal naturel est vital d'aller voir un
film au cinéma et pour cela il faut
évidemment être éduqués à cela si vous
n'êtes pas éduqué à cela by a aucune
raison que vous disiez bah tiens
j'allais voir un film donc la région se
tient un dispositif à lycéens apprentis
au cinéma qui permet justement aux
lycéens de découvrir l'image de
découvrir ce qu'est un film ce qu'il ya
derrière un film d'être éduqué à cela et
puis on essaye aussi de lancer des
ciné-clubs 1 dans les différents lycées
d'ile-de-france et de pousser également
à des partenariats avec des organismes
comme lina pour permettre des formations
dans les métiers du cinéma et pendant
toute la durée du festival de cannes
radio sensations un partenariat avec tv
60,18 vous fait vivre l'événement de
l'intérieur en allant à la rencontre des
réalisateurs producteurs et acteurs de
notre région corentin alonso nous emmène
ce vendredi à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs c'est une sélection
parallèle au festival une francilienne y
figuraient notamment cette année c'est
alice vino cours pour son dernier film
revoir paris la quinzaine des
réalisateurs est un concours parallèle
au festival de cannes la réalisatrice
alice vino cours est venu y présenter
son dernier film revoir paris l'histoire
de millas joué par virginie efira prise
dans un attentat terroriste
le film suit son cheminement elle ne se
souvient pas de tous les événements et
mène son enquête pour se rappeler et se
reconstruire
pour ce film la réalisatrice s'est
inspiré du témoignage de son petit frère
parce que mon petit frère était dans le
bataclan il a survécu évidemment le film
ne parle pas du bata crainte d'un
attentat imaginaire mais c'est vraiment
oui voilà j'avais envie de faire un film
deux ayant c'est un film de
reconstruction sur cette question en
fait un monstre en fait une communauté
extrêmement soudée de victimes qui
essaye de se reconstruire de se
reconstruire ensemble après les
événements ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
pas l'événement de l'attentât en soi
mais c'est les traces qu'elle a laissé
chez les victimes qui se rappellent que
de fragments en fait un film conclut
déjà voir les festivaliers à cannes le
tournage a été bouclé en décembre et le
montage a été finalisé un jour seulement
avant le début du festival et la salle a
été plutôt conquise écoutez je trouve
que c'est intéressant parce que ça parle
de la mémoire traumatique train de taper
exactement des événements des faits et
sa part de la mémoire traumatique mais
on se reconstruit après ça comment on
reconstruit les événements qu'on a vécu
est qu'on a oublié de manière volontaire
ou non c'est un film bouleversant je
trouve qu'ils laissent pas indifférent
bien sûr qui remue beaucoup
pour les autres il faudra attendre
encore un peu avant de voir le film sur
les écrans la date de sortie n'a pas
encore été dévoilé mais ça sera d'ici la
fin de l'année une nouvelle semaine se
termine dans les yvelines et malgré le
pont de l'ascension l'actualité a été
riche dans le département ce qu'il faut
retenir on vous le résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
premier conseil des ministres pour le
gouvernement d'elizabeth banks était une
première pour la députée des yvelines il
ya une brawn peavey désormais ministre d
outre-mer et aussi pour sylvie
retailleau ex présidente de l'université
paris saclay nommé à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche
autre nouveau pape ndiaye le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a choisi les
yvelines pour son premier déplacement il
s'est rendu au collège du bois dole de
nos conflans sainte honorine là où
enseignait samuel pâtit le professeur a
été assassiné le 16 octobre 2020 un
grand colloque sur la cybersécurité il
était organisée au théâtre montansier
par le mouvement européen des yvelines
un sujet de société primordial pour les
particuliers les entreprises et les
collectivités locales depuis la crise
sanitaire le nombre de cyberattaques a
explosé il était très compliqué de
circuler en ile de france mercredi en
raison des départs pour le long week-end
de l'ascension attention si vous avez
prévu de revenir dimanche bison futé
voit noir au niveau national il est
conseillé de rouler avant midi dans la
région les bouchons sont prévus jusqu'au
moins 19 heures voire 20 heures et puis
le soulagement à jouars-pontchartrain
après 16 heures de recherches la mère de
famille de 44 ans portée disparue a été
retrouvée saine et sauve elle avait déjà
tenté de mettre fin à ses jours il ya
deux semaines un énorme dispositif a été
déployé par la gendarmerie avec
hélicoptère et chiens renifleurs une
centaine d'habitants a également prêté
main forte aux forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
et votre guide c'est bien sûr bixente
mais rien senti très bonne qui nous
emmène pour commencer du côté de
rambouillet une formation qui fait son
retour on a fait grégory la fanfare de
cavalerie du 501e régiment de chars de
combat dissoute en 1994 renaît de ses
cendres un entièrement va créer une
association musicale nommée fr 501 en
2021 il regroupe tous les anciens
musiciens militaires qui sont passés par
cette fanfare samedi 28 et dimanche 29
mai 55 musiciens bretons remonteront sur
scène à rambouillet pour un instant
nostalgique le reportage de célia 4 go
allons-y armes blindée cavalerie
pour certains il n'avait pas répété
depuis 30 ans la fanfare de cavalerie du
501e régiment de chars de combat est de
retour pour le week-end de l'ascension à
rambouillet une cinquantaine de
musiciens retrouvent leurs instruments
thierry bergeaud a commencé en 1983 en
tant qu'instrumentiste il est passé de
chef de pupitre pour arriver à adjoint
de trop bête major trente ans après 30
ans pour les plus jeunes
on a l'impression de les avoir quittés
il ya deux semaines voyagent juste un
petit peu de vacances on les retrouve et
puis hop on repart tous les réflexions
là on retrouve vraiment l'impression de
fanfare de cavalerie surtout celle du
501 parce qu'on avait quand même un son
fonds phare du 500 m
et puis d'un coup d'essai
pour moi c'est un grand honneur en tout
cas cette fanfare avait à l'époque une
renommée internationale
elle était composée de 80 % d'appeler
les 20% d'engager avant d'être dissoute
en 1994 elles participaient tous les ans
au défilé du 14 juillet à paris
souvent statique devant la tribune
officielle elle joué pendant le défilé
des chars avaient donc de regarder sur
les champs-elysées et en 89 en 1989 ils
ont fait une évolution sur sur
l'esplanade en fait tu sois sur la place
de la concorde où vont l'appeler bouffe
le après trois répétitions en région
depuis jeudi 26 mai les musiciens qui
viennent de toute la france répète dans
la salle patenôtre à rambouillet au
programme un répertoire pur cavalerie
mais aussi de la fantaisie sur scène
trompette de cavalerie cor trompette bas
seront encore un ensemble de percussions
ça prend on l'a en fait tout ça vous
prend jeolla au coeur ici là ça vous
prend ici parce que ça vous prend aux
tripes
mois hier
des musiciens qui avaient petite larme
c'est pour vous dire que ça remue
beaucoup et d'ailleurs si la fanfare du
sens on n'avait pas une telle qualité on
serait pas là aujourd'hui c'est en
fêtant son album d'armé l'année dernière
que david falentin a voulu reprendre
contact avec ses camarades en temps ils
ont créé un groupe facebook qui regroupe
maintenant environ 120 musiciens moi
j'ai bonne idée comme ça tu bosses mais
quelques morceaux
pop aussi c'est un truc c'est infaisable
effectivement si ça ça paraissait
irréalisable on ouvre au maximum et on
interdit mêlant la guerre aux gens
54 rendez vous donc samedi 28 mai à 15
heures place de la lanterne et dimanche
29 mai à 10h30 salle patenôtre des
personnalités seront présentes comme des
généraux ou encore gérard larcher ancien
maître anglais
on souhaite bien sûr bon retour à cette
fanfare une autre idée de sortie pour ce
week-end bixente on en parle beaucoup
sur tv 78 et le football-club de
versailles et c'est aussi une bonne
occasion de sortir dans les yvelines le
football-club de versailles plus que
jamais ce samedi grégory vous avez
raison ce 28 mai rendez vous festif au
stade mont boron de versailles à 18
heures c'est le dernier match de la
saison de l'équipe championne de
nationale 2 le fc versailles souhaite
clôture est justement cette saison en
fanfare avec la réception du blois foot
41 ponctuée de plusieurs animations on
aura distribution de tee-shirts écharpes
et drapeaux du club jeu a le jeu de la
barre à la mi-temps sandwich offert pour
tous et plein d'autres surprises
l'entrée est gratuite pour célébrer avec
le plus grand nombre une saison
exceptionnelle le titre en nationale 2
et vous vous souvenez galerie un
parcours historique en coupe de france
et cette demi finale oui bien sûr bravo
au football club de versailles on se
souvient de ce parcours exceptionnel on
avait eu l'occasion et la chance aussi à
itv 78 de pouvoir suivre notamment le
déplacement on était parti du côté
de bergerac est déjà oubliée voilà de
bergerac mais c'était pour affronter
alors c'est à périgueux mais bergerac
c'est pour ça que j'avais la petite la
petite hésitation dans ma tête alors
comment sait on si on commence à se
projeter dans le dans les prochains
week-end puisque dans le cercle week-end
on parle des idées de sorties du
week-end on se projette aussi au week
end après vous voulez nous présenter un
événement à ne pas manquer alors ce sera
même en début de semaine prochaine dans
les yvelines en effet grégory c'est la
deuxième édition d'un événement créé par
des agrumes youtuber agri youtuber le
tracteur tour 2022 est parti hier jeudi
26 mai de versailles ils sont quatre à
avoir pris ce départ de la pièce d'eau
des suisses et ils repasseront mardi 31
mai prochain dans les yvelines à poigny
la forêt pour les présenter brièvement
grégory ce sont des agriculteurs plutôt
bien suivie sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ont décidé des suites de la pandémie de
co vite d'aller directement à la
rencontre des français ils ont réalisé
une première édition l'année dernière
entre châteauroux la vendée et la
bretagne où il ne s'attendait pas à un
tel succès c'est pourquoi il réitère
l'opération
leur but mettre en lumière l'agriculture
française et les paysans locaux on
écoute à ce propos l'un des participants
alexandre perron on s'arrête deux fois
par jour une fois de 11h à 13h et une
autre fois de 16 à 18 et on essaye par
jour de faire une commune rurale et une
exploitation agricole on veut faire
découvrir
par ce tracteur tour les communes et les
exploitations alors pourquoi avoir
choisi les yvelines grégory vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir qu'étant dans lieux
lointaine de paris notre département se
compose de nombreuses zones dites
périurbaines chez nous c'est la
frontière entre ville et campagne une
promiscuité direct entre citadins et
agriculteurs autant de laquelle ces
youtuber du tracteur tôt veulent
discuter l'intérêt est aussi de notre
communication ces deux expliquer aux
gens qui ne connaissent pas le monde
agricole en gros le grand public ce
qu'est l'agriculture telle qu'on t'aime
quand la vie est telle qu on la
travaille aujourd'hui et il ya un gros
manque de communication dans
l'agriculture quand on voit surtout dans
des régions comme l'ile-de-france on a
souvent des problématiques les
agriculteurs souvent des problématiques
avec les voisins et on le voit quand les
gens sortaient pompe à traiter quand les
agriculteurs sont sorte les pu lever
où les épandeurs d'engrais tout de suite
ça va être la pollution quand on voit
les canaux à roue qui tourne en ce
moment alors qu'il fait chaud je pense
que on pense que nous il faut expliquer
tout simplement pourquoi on le fait et
surtout expliquer aux gens que
l'agriculture française et l'une des
plus vertueuses et qualitatif du monde
mais les gens ne savent pas alors voilà
vous me direz la grue ou l idée de
sortie là dedans et bien ce tracteur
tour partie des yvelines qui est
maintenant en ce moment je crois dans
les hauts de seine revient dans les
yvelines pour sa dernière étape ce sera
mardi 31 mai à poigne et la forêt après
cinq jours de périple les quatre pilotes
et leurs tracteurs veulent arrêter
justement leur véhicule et terminé
l'aventuré en bonne et due forme
l'intérêt c'était d'arriver vers 16h en
plus j'ai horreur des écoles hier la
sortie des écoles tous les enfants
adorent voir les tracteurs on a des
petits cadeaux pour eux les parents
pourront voir les différences
agriculteurs qui seront là et puis
goûter un petit peu ce qui se fait et on
leur expliquera en même temps comment on
produit on transforme alors on va
peut-être un peu sur les rotules mais on
aura plein de souvenirs alors raconté
plein de choses à leur dire parler
d'agriculture en plus cela ils vont
avoir un panel
d'agriculture différentes de l'élevage
alors agri youtuber mais aussi des
producteurs qui se rend sur place donc
c'est vraiment le moment parce que de
toute façon on fait une région par an on
va pas revenir tout de suite dans les
idées
donc venez nous voir voilà donc rendez
vous mardi prochain du côté de poignées
la forêt mais aussi très prochainement
sur la chaîne youtube du tracteur tour
pour une rétrospective de leurs voyages
et pas de panique grégory je vous
entendez tout à leur parler du trafic ce
dimanche ce ne sera pas de la faute du
tracteur tour puisque lors ce qu'ils
arpentent les routes ils sont escortés
par une première voiture avec un
gyrophare ils font le maximum pour ne
pas encombrer la situation il se mettre
sur le côté il s'arrête et ils vous
laissent passer ce n'est pas donc de
leur faute si l'alerté est donnée et
bien sûr pour en apprendre toujours plus
sur le travail des agriculteurs rendez
vous sur les chaînes youtube des
participants en l'occurrence alex
agriculture vienne alexandre de prod ils
center qu'on a entendu et les autres
puisqu'ils sont sept à avoir monté le
tour 2022 franchement grégory c'est
super intéressant allez découvrir
puisque c'est vrai que c'est un milieu
qu'on ne connaît pas tous très bien et
pourtant qui touchent directement
directement à notre vie de tous les
jours il ya un secteur ô combien
important pour notre département des
yvelines vous le disiez avec beaucoup de
côtes et périurbain c'est à cheval entre
l'urbain et le rural ce territoire est
des yvelines on passe encore à des
agendas toujours à venir dans les
yvelines pour le week-end prochain cette
fois ci est une expédition sur les flots
c'est ce que vous nous promettez vous
nous vendez un peu du rêve dans sa
galerie 1h30 de croisière donc c'est un
peu l'esprit vacances une croisière
supplément découverte le dimanche 5 juin
prochain au départ de la halte fluviale
de bougival la croisière des
impressionnistes vous emmènera
tranquillement paisiblement dans
l'univers des peintres qui ont puisé
leur inspiration des bords de seine
yvelinois renoir monet sisley 1h30 donc
de balades fluviales pour en apprendre
plus sur ces grands noms de la peinture
à prévoir quand même un petit pique
nique et selon le temps crème solaire ou
couvents voilà ça dépend il vaut mieux
avoir préparé les choses là plutôt que
d'être surpris tarif fixé à 24 euros
informations et réservations sur le site
versailles tirer tourisme.com et des
sorties tout le mois de juin ça faire
tout le mois de juin maintenant un peu
plus à terre exactement grégory les
collectionneurs les revendeurs et les
enfants attendent ces journées toute
l'année la saison des vide greniers est
ouverte à chaque fois c'est un peu une
pression est ce qu'on va tout vendre
est-ce qu'on va dénicher la perle rare
ou tout simplement est ce qu'il va faire
beau mais c'est surtout beaucoup de
plaisir faire des bonnes affaires se
débarrasser de vieilles babioles ou
simplement discuter se promener le
week-end des 4 et 5 juin beaucoup de
brocante seront présentes dans les
yvelines samedi verneuil-sur-seine airs
murray dampierre rambouillet ou epône
pour n'en citer que quatre le dimanche
en tout cas tous sur tout le mois de
juin plus de 50 communes organisent leur
vide greniers rien que ça pour savoir si
la vôtre participent il suffit de
checker voilà le site internet des
communes où le site broeck à brac qui
répertorie les différentes dates on a
commencé votre sélection des idées de
sorties en musique et on va la termine
en musique michel theuil avec un rendez
vous assez exceptionnel du côté du zoo
de thoiry un triple concert avec
l'artiste connu pour ses talents de
beatboxing mbe 14 la tête d'affiche
yannick noah et un troisième invité
surprise voilà qu'on ne connaît pas
encore voici un petit aperçu de ce qui
vous attend
[Musique]
et là on sait dans le vent calais
e
tout enfant
ça
[Musique]
voilà donc pour cette idée de sortie
merci bixente bon week-end à vous vous
avez prévu de faire quoi vous ce week
end une célébration de versailles
peut-être qu'on a beaucoup suivi ça peut
toujours être intéressant en plus sans
doute gratuit moi ça me fascine c'est
peut-être que je vous accompagnerai pour
cette célébration du football club de
versailles et c'est la fin de ce set
week-end merci est d'avoir été avec nous
l'information locale qui revient à des
lundis à 18 heures avec le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 et d'ici là bien sûr
passer un excellent week-end
[Musique]